[Musique]
ce n'est qu'à la mi mars que justin
trudeau a vraiment réalisé à quel point
la crise du coronavirus était grave
c'est ce qu'il a révélé dans l'entretien
qu'il m'a accordée ce midi pour faire le
bilan de cette année une année qui a été
évidemment bouleversé par la pandémie
et s'il tire des leçons sur le faible
niveau de préparation du pays
il ne regrette ni sa gestion de la crise
ni les milliards de dollars dépensés
pour soutenir l'économie
voyons tout de suite la première partie
de cette entrevue c'est le premier
ministre bonjour bonjour cellule
monsieur trudeau les premières
vaccinations commence on voit enfin la
lumière au bout du tunnel ça doit être
un soulagement pour vous c'est un grand
soulagement évidemment c'est peut-être
le seulement le début de la fin mais on
sent quand même que il va avoir une fin
à cette pandémie alors c'est important
évidemment de ne pas trop vouloir se
laisser rallye va falloir qu'on qu'on
passe l'hiver est la grande majorité
d'entre nous encore faire très attention
mais on voit que au printemps rendu à
l'été ça devrait aller beaucoup mieux et
ça va nous donner de l'énergie pour
encore faire les bonnes choses
ouais si les gens se font vacciner parce
que ce matin dans un essai h et celle
des housses a commencé au québec et
beaucoup de travailleurs de la santé qui
hésitaient à se faire vacciner tout de
suite qui disait on va attendre 60 %
c'est quand même beaucoup
de toute façon on commence avec des
petites quantités parce que le processus
de produire de ces nouveaux vaccins
commence tranquillement à prendre de
l'ampleur alors ça nous donne
l'opportunité de pratiquer la logistique
de s'assurer que tout est vielle l'armée
est là dessus le manager général fortin
mais on a aussi nos experts en santé
publique qui nous rassure que ce vaccin
il ya sécuritaire et efficace pour les
canadiens alors vous est ce que vous
allez vous faire vacciner et quand vous
allez vous faire vacciner
je me fais vacciner avec enthousiasme
quand le moment viendra évidemment
vous donnez la priorité aux personnes
les plus vulnérables mais dès que
j'aurai j'aurai la chance comme tous les
adultes en forme comme moi je vais y
être de façon très visible et
enthousiaste donc pas de priorité pour
les dirigeants du pays même si par
exemple si on allait en campagne
électorale est ce que ça serait pas une
bonne idée vous faire vacciner avant je
pense qu'on n'a pu être démontré que un
pisse se gère même très bien si on est
pris à la maison un petit peu il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont découvert que
leur emploi pouvait plus se faire la
maison c'est sûr que c'est toujours un
peu plus compliqué mais ça ce fait il
faut vraiment donner priorité aux
travailleurs de la santé aux personnes
les plus vulnérables et j'ai eu aucune
difficulté avec soleil et damman alors
c'est un début quand même modeste mais
l'objectif c'est que tous les canadiens
selon votre plan soient vaccinés d'ici
septembre prochain alors est ce que ça
veut dire que c'est seulement à ce
moment là qu'on pourra retrouver une vie
normale d'après vous c'est la question
que tout le monde se pose
les scientifiques et les experts sont en
train de travailler justement sur cette
question pour savoir à quel niveau de la
population vaccinée est-ce qu'on peut
commencer à réduire les restrictions un
peu commencé à retourner un petit peu
vers la morale normal est-ce que c'est
50 % est ce que c'est 60%
tout ça ce sera à voir et à étudier mais
on va le faire le plus rapidement
possible c'est certain mais ce sera pas
probablement avant la fin de l'hiver
c'est sûr alors la fin de l'hiver alors
j'aimerais mais surtout qu'on revienne
un petit peu en arrière parce qu'il ya
neuf mois personne n'aurait pu imaginer
qu'on en serait encore là et à quel
moment vous
vous avez réalisé que c'était grave que
le monde allait soudainement changé je
pense que c'était vraiment lalani mars
on voyait un peu des cas ici et là
quelques cas de voyageurs au canada en
février début mars
mais là évidemment quand sophie est
revenue d'un voyage d'affaires à londres
et est là elle a été testé positif pour
la kfw 19
évidemment ça a été un bouleversement
pour pour pomper maison pour ma famille
mais ça a été aussi un moment pour
beaucoup de gens de dire ok c'est
sérieux on s'en va en confinement on va
prendre les mesures nécessaires et
pendant une semaine on va qu on avait
complètement transformé à la situation
de la de la vie de tous les jours des
gens pour pour se protéger est ce que le
canada aurait pu mieux se préparer dans
les premiers mois parce qu'on se
souvient quand même vous parlez du
confinement du mois de mars mais dès le
mois de janvier on voyait ce qui se
passait en chine et les autorités
sanitaires canadiennes disait fin
janvier or les risques d'une pandémie
sont faibles au canada
est ce qu'on aurait pu mieux se préparer
c'est sûr qu'on aurait pu mieux faire
au mois de janvier la docteure d'amd
avait déjà des rencontres avec ses
homologues pour parler de ce nouveau
virus qui sortait de la chine
nous on a vu des rencontres du groupe
d'urgence pour à pourvoir
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire mais c'est
certain que le monde n'était pas préparé
pour cette pandémie et on a beaucoup de
faits d'apprentissage qui vont on
l'espère nous aider si jamais il y en
aura d'autres mais qu'est ce que vous
allez faire en priorité pour assurer la
sécurité sanitaire des canadiens la
prochaine fois s'il ya une prochaine
fois d'abord serait de s'assurer que on
un autre projet âge de d'équipements de
protection adéquate qu'on a des règles
et des principes en place pour que les
gens puissent peut savoir exactement
quoi faire dans une pandémie ça fait ça
fait plus que 100 tant qu'on n'a pas
vécu une pandémie de ceux de ce style
dans le monde et l'apprentissage n'était
n'était plus là on avait beaucoup appris
de la sas à toronto mais évident il ya
20 ans mais même un sens on va voir
beaucoup de choses de plus sa fin et
c'est pour ça avec 8 $ sur 10 dépenser à
pour contrer la kfw dépensés par le
fédéral ont depuis démontré que on parle
mieux à travers une pandémie comme ça
quand on est là pour appuyer les gens
oui ça m'amène à vos finances publiques
parce que vous avez annoncé justement un
déficit anticipé de 382 milliards et ça
inclut même pas ce que vous comptez
dépensés pour la relance jusqu'à 100
milliards alors il ya beaucoup de gens
qui s'inquiètent quand même de toutes
ces dépenses jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à
aller justement est-ce qu'un cap pour
vous ou qui ne peut pas être dépassé on
va faire tout ce qui est nécessaire
aussi longtemps que ce sera nécessaire
pour appuyer les gens c'est la promesse
que j'ai faite mais mes pensez-y
d'abord cette pandémie allait amener des
grandes difficultés économiques société
inévitable la question devient qui
devrait s'endetter d une famille
empreinte sur sa carte de crédit à 19%
nous un gouvernement fédéral on emprunte
à presque zéro pour cent donc pour payer
l'épicerie pour payer le loyer pour
protéger les les petites entreprises le
gouvernement fédéral était mieux placé
on s'est endetté pour que les gens n'est
pas à le faire alors on a sauvé
énormément maintenant mais en plus
d'avoir éviter la destruction économique
massive qu'on est en train de voir
ailleurs dans le monde parce qu'on a pu
appuyer les gens ça va nous permettre de
reprendre mieux et plus rapidement que
bien d'autres pays en avait on avait la
situation économique la plus
forte du g7 en entrant dans son déni et
même maintenant avec toutes ces dépenses
on est encore dans la meilleure
situation économique des pays du g7 donc
pas de limite pendant la pandémie c'est
ce que vous dites
effectivement on va appuyer les gens
avec tout ce qui est nécessaire pendant
aussi longtemps que c'est nécessaire
mais alors est ce que ça veut dire
qu'après la pandémie les canadiens dans
se préparer à des hausses d'impôts et de
taxes parce qu'il va bien falloir
rembourser comme j'ai dis avec les taux
d'intérêt étant quasiment 1 0 dès qu'on
commence à avoir la croissance
économique
on n'aura pas à s'inquiéter de sow est
ce que vous vous engagez à ce qu ils pas
de hausse d'impôts de taxes pour les
canadiens c'est sûr on ne va pas en
imposer plus haut au canadien on sait
que il faut reprendre l'économie c'est
pas le temps d'enlever aux gens s'ils
temps d'encore offrir des opportunités
aux gens de passer à travers et rebâtir
l'économie plus forte pour les années à
venir
donc pour les provinces vous le savez la
priorité ce sont les transferts
récurrent en santé vous avez ouvert la
porte la semaine dernière après cette
rencontre que vous avez vu avec les
premiers ministres
mais vous dites plus tard sauf que les
coûts de santé ils augmentent pour les
provinces la technologie le
vieillissement de la population
alors qu'est ce que vous allez faire est
ce que vous allez leur donner ou pas oui
on va leur donner plus d'argent dans les
transferts de santé c'est une promesse
que j'ai faite au premier ministre tout
ce que j'ai dit et je l' ai démontré
d'ailleurs c'est que on va être là pour
cette pandémie
on a été là pour puisque 25 milliards de
dollars pour aider les provinces
on va faire encore plus et ceci par
dessus tout l'argent qu'on donne
directement aux québécois et aux
canadiens d'un bout à l'autre du pays
mais par rapport à ce sera quoi pour le
long terme mais par son à travers de
cette crise économique cette crise
sanitaire et ensuite on sera mieux
positionné pour pouvoir regarder ça va
être quoi nos dépenses dans les années à
venir aussi que iad innovation et d
apprentissage qu'on est en train de
faire par rapport à cette pandémie
qui vont nous permettre de faire les
choses différemment dans l'avenir et le
fédéral va être là pour aider les gens
la hausse de 28 milliards que demandent
les provinces monsieur trudeau est ce
que c'est dans l'ordre du possible pour
vous combien vous pouvez dépenser là
dessus on a dépensé des dizaines et des
milliards des presque des centaines de
milliards de dollars pendant cette
endémie pour aider les familles pour
investir dans les systèmes de santé pour
pour appuyer les canadiens pendant
qu'ils en avaient besoin pour des
dépenses récurrentes long terme je pense
que c'est responsable d'attendre la fin
de cette crise actuelle pour pouvoir
savoir quel sera le bon montant mais
nous on le sait déjà monsieur on ne sait
pas des gens un peu monsieur trudeau
quand même ceux dont les provinces ont
besoin en ce moment
ben oui et en ce moment on l'envoie de
l'argent pour les aider
[Musique]
alors il ya bien sûr la pandémie qui a
été votre priorité pendant tout cette
année mais il ya quand même quelques
autres gros sujets d'actualité notamment
la défaite de donald tron alors il est
parti maintenant toute fin pratique est
ce que vous pouvez nous dire qu'est ce
que vous avez trouvé le plus difficile
dans cette relation
les relations avec les états unis
c'est toujours compliqué j'ai commencé
avec obama on s'entendait bien a certain
niveau mais il y avait des enjeux comme
comme au niveau du bois d'oeuvre qu'on
n'a pas pu régler avec avec dans la
halle 30
évidemment il était plus protectionniste
un petit peu on a eu le grand défi de
renégocier l'alena d'avoir pu s'en
sortir avec un meilleur deal on a pu
protéger notre économie canadienne notre
accès au marché américain on a pu
défendre nos travailleurs d'acier
d'aluminium surtout oui ce lieu des
défis comme il y en a toujours mais on
ne puisse en tirer assez bien je pense
en tant que pays parce que quand même ce
traîneau je comprends et je viens de
pouvoir continuer d'avoir de bonnes
relations avec les états unis ont depuis
géré le président entre hommes qui
étaient tout à fait et prévisible des
fois mais si jamais facile bien gérer
les relations avec les états unis même
même si le président est plus plus
aligné sur certaines choses comme on
l'espère que monsieur buydens laissera
alors on verra dès l'année prochaine
comment va se passer cette nouvelle
relation mais parlons d'une relation
avec une autre grande puissance qui est
très complexe
c'est la chine selon certains médias les
autorités américaines tentent en ce
moment de négocier une entente avec la
femme d'affaires de huawei même où joe
pour lui permettre de rentrer en chine
certains y voient un peu d'espoir
monsieur trudeau pour ces deux canadiens
qui vont passer un troisième noël en
prison là en chine
est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord est ce que vous y voyez un
signe d'espoir depuis les débuts notre
priorité a été de ramener ces deux
canadiens qui ont été détenues de façon
entièrement arbitraire réponse à un
geste tout à fait responsable du [ __ ] du
canada de respecter notre et et à
l'international mais jusqu'ici ça fait
deux ans votre approche certains disent
qu'elle est très timide à l'égard de
l'aide de pékin
est ce que ce serait pas le temps d'être
plus ferme pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes
quoi plus ferme envers la chine
d'ailleurs on est assez ferme par un peu
sur différents enjeux comme les
canadiens s'attendent à ce qu'on soit
mais notre priorité c'est de ramener ces
deux marques au oui j'imagine que vous
avez une pensée pour eux en ces temps de
noël
monsieur trudeau parlons d'un autre
sujet un peu délicat la loi 101 sur le
déclin du français
il ya unanimité à l'assemblée nationale
pour imposer la loi 101 aux entreprises
de compétence fédérale au québec tous
les partis d'opposition à la chambre des
communes sont pour alors qu'est ce qui
vous fait hésiter si tout le monde est
d'accord et et j'ai aussi énormément
apprécié la lettre de tous les ans et
premier ministre du québec qui souligne
l'importance de défendre le français je
suis tout à fait d'accord montant que
gouvernement fédéral j'ai non seulement
comme on l'a dit dans un discours du
trône la responsabilité de protéger la
langue française au québec où le recul
du français mais qui est énormément
j'ai aussi la responsabilité de la
protéger partout au pays
on est le seul pays en amérique du nord
où on parle français donc d'avancer avec
une modernisation de la loi sur les
langues officielles c'est ce qu'on va
faire
ce trio je suis toujours là pour
défendre la loi 101 c'est important que
pour que le canada soit un pays bilingue
que le francophone soit d'abord et avant
que le québec soit d'abord et avant tout
francophone en tant que québécois en
tant que canadiens jeu toujours défendra
langue française et la loi 101
une importance une grande importance
pour justement protéger le français au
québec et vont continuer d'être
important vous fermait pas la porte
c'est ce qu'on comprend monsieur trudeau
il ya le devoir qui nous apprend que les
francophones sont quasiment absents de
la diplomatie canadienne comment est-ce
qu'on peut justifier ça il n'y a pas un
ambassadeur francophones à part isabelle
hudon et stéphane dion dans les pays du
g20 il ya un employé qui disait c'est
comme si on était aux années dans les
années 50 les francophones travail sur
le plancher et les patrons sont des
anglophones bas d'abord je pense que
notre ministre des affaires étrangères
françois philippe champagne serait
fortement en désaccord avec avec cela
vous avez nommé deux de nos plus
importants ambassadeurs et stéphane dion
isabelle hudon
mais on en a d'autres aussi on va
continuer de chercher et de trouver de
bons francophone pour nous représenter à
travers le pays à travers le monde oui
j'ai été troublé par ce rapport et on
est en train de travailler pour
s'assurer qu'on qu'on réalise un petit
peu les chiffres
dernier dossier monsieur trudeau c'est
un dossier sur lequel vous avez été
interpellé vous même directement par le
new york times et c'est celui du géant
la pornographie pour une robe qui est
situé à montréal qui héberge des vidéos
d'agression d'exploitation sexuelle de
mineurs
personnellement vous est ce que vous
êtes à l'aise qu'on abrite le plus gros
joueur de la porno de la planète
ouais ce qui me préoccupe énormément
c'est l'exploitation des enfants
la pornographie juvénile est la violence
l'harcèlement l'intimidation
tous ces éléments là et on a des des
lois très ferme contre c'est ses actes
ils responsables et les gars liligo
parce que la 1000ème la mairesse plantes
de montréal amer la mairesse de montréal
dit que l on veut pas quoi de ce genre
de sites qui présentent des contenus
dégradant de la pédophilie des viols la
torture alors on devrait pouvoir agir
rapidement dans ce dossier mais se
trouve effectivement et on est en train
justement de d'établir une
réglementation très forte là dessus qui
va sortir bientôt
parce que finalement elle s'achève cette
année 2020 s'il y avait un mot pour la
décrire pour vous qu'est ce que ce
serait et c'était une année difficile
c'est certain mais en même temps on a vu
à quel point ils canadiens sont là les
uns pour les autres ça a été une année
de tragédies de familles qui ont perdu
des êtres chers de difficultés
économiques et financières et sanitaires
mais en même temps je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ont découvert à
quel point en tant que communauté en
tant que voisin en tant que canadiens on
peut passer à travers des moments
extrêmement difficiles et en 2021 des
élections ce printemps ou non on verra
bien notre priorité c'est la pandémie
s'est scellée vaccins ont cédé comme
vous avez dit c'était très bonne
nouvelle qu'on a maintenant des vaccins
mais la vaccination ça va être la
priorité pour lire les mois à venir et
on espère pouvoir faire fonctionner le
parlement avec avec tous les différents
partis et ça va se passer comment noël
chez vous parce que tous les canadiens
la plupart en tout cas vont être
combinés on va être confiné ça va être
là la famille proche seulement pas de
pot de cousins
des appels zone c'est certain mais pas
d'ami pas de cousins en restant en petit
du léon on pense en passe du temps avec
les êtres les plus chers
on va vous souhaiter de joyeuses fêtes
monsieur trudeau merci beaucoup pour cet
entretien
ça me fait toujours plaisir bonne soirée